Speaker 1: We do have primary results from last
night. The primary coverage was sort of replaced
in a great sense by this horrible, tragic mass
shooting in Uvalde, Texas. But there were primary
results, as some of you know. Donald Trump's new
obsession is his endorsement record. Now, I have
to tell you, it's all kind of meaningless. Trump
mostly endorses people that are already winning
or incumbents or obvious favorites. And so, like
your record, when you're endorsing mostly people
that are obviously going to win, it doesn't
really mean that much. But okay, Trump is
obsessed with his endorsement record. Trump
had some humiliating losses last night. I mean,
absolutely humiliating losses in the Georgia
gubernatorial primary, the Republican primary
in Georgia. Donald Trump endorsed David
Perdue, the former Republican senator.
On the other hand, Mike Pence endorsed Brian Kemp,
the incumbent Georgia governor. It's not normal
for a president and a vice president so recently
out of office to be on the opposite sides of
races like this. But Trump endorsed David Perdue.
David Perdue was crushed by more than 50 points.
This is one of the most humiliating losses
in recent political history among well-known
candidates. Okay, sure. Often you've got an
incumbent against a no name and they win by 59.
This is a different situation. This was actually
supposedly going to be a real race. And Brian
Kemp defeated David Perdue 74 to 22, a stunning
victory for Kemp and a trouncing for Donald Trump.
We then went to the Georgia Republican secretary
of state primary. This is a really important race.
This is who controls the election in the state of
Georgia. Brad Raffensperger Easily defeating Jody
Hice. Trump endorsed Jody Hice. Brad Raffensperger
won by nearly 20 points. Now Trump got himself
some wins. Without a doubt. Herschel Walker won
and etc.. But two major, major losses for the
failed former president. Now, some other important
results from yesterday. Stacey Abrams won in
Georgia. This was a formality. This was she was
unopposed in the Democratic gubernatorial primary.
Stacey Abrams will now face Brian Kemp in
November. That's a really important election.
And when we talk about what are some of
the most important elections, there are
so many in November. But we've talked about how
Pennsylvania Senate could ultimately decide who
controls the Senate in the next Congress. That's
going to be important. There's lots of really
important races. Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
running there that could set the tone for 2024.
Abrams versus camp in Georgia is a big, big deal.
Now also from Georgia in the 14th District. Yes,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE easily won her primary.
There was every expectation that she would she
had roughly 70% of the vote. Marcus Flowers
easily won on the Democratic side, so they
will face each other. That's a really great race
to get involved in, in the sense that defeating
Marjorie Taylor GREENE in particular after the
defeat of Madison Cawthorn, it would be amazing.
But as far as a general election, Georgia's 14th
District is very red and it's going to be an
uphill battle. And then lastly, in the Arkansas
Republican gubernatorial primary, as expected,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders easily won. She's Donald
Trump's former White House press secretary.
She will likely win the governorship. Chris
Jones won the Democratic primary for governor
and in November it will be Chris Jones against
Sarah Huckabee Sanders, a very red state. It is,
you know, speaking speaking honestly with
you. It's difficult to imagine that there
would be a real opportunity for Chris Jones
there, but potentially another race to follow.
So some humiliations for Donald Trump last night
when he posted he posted today to his platform
truth, social truth central.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: He barely spoke about the ones that
he lost, focusing only on the win. So not not a
major surprise. Next week, more primaries, which
we will be covering. And all of these stories
will have more coverage on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.